I didn't know when I agreed to do this
whether I was expected to to talk or to
sing but when I was told that the topic
was language I felt that I had to speak
about something for a moment I have a
problem it's not the worst thing in the
world I'm fine I'm not on fire I know
that other people in the world have far
worse things to to deal with but for me
language and music are inextricably
linked through this one thing and the
thing is that I have a stutter
it might seem curious given that I spend
a lot of my life on this stage one would
assume that I'm comfortable in the
public sphere and comfortable here
speaking to you guys but the truth is
that I have spent my life up into this
point and including this point living in
mortal dread of public speaking public
singing a whole different thing
but we'll get to that in a moment I've
never really talked about it before so
explicitly I think that that's because
I've always lived in hope that when I
was a grown up I wouldn't have have one
I sort of lived with this idea that went
on growing
I'll have learned to speak French and
when I'm growing I'll learn how to
manage my money and when I'm growing I
won't have a stutter and then I'll be
able to public speaking maybe be the
Prime Minister and anything's possible
and you know so so I can talk about it
now because I've reached this point
where I mean I'm 28 I'm pretty sure that
I'm grown now
and I'm an adult woman who spends her
life as a performer with a speech
impediment so I might as well come clean
about it
there are some interesting angles to
having a stutter from me the worst thing
that can happen is meeting and another
stutterer this happened to me in Hamburg
when this guy what we've met and he said
hello
my name is Joe and I said oh hello my
name is Meg imagine my horror when I
realized he thought I was making fun of
him
people think I'm drunk all the time
people think that I've forgotten their
name when I hesitate before saying it
and it's a it is a very weird thing
because proper nouns are the worst if
I'm gonna use the word will Wednesday in
a sentence and I'm I'm coming up to the
word and I can feel that I'm gonna
stutter or something I can change the
word to tomorrow or the day after
Tuesday or something else you know it
it's it's clunky but you can get away
with it because over time I've developed
this loophole method of using speech
where right at the last minute you
change the thing and you trick your
brain but with people's names you can't
change them
when I was singing a lot of jazz I
worked a lot with a pianist whose name
was Steve as you can probably gather s's
and T's together or independently
I liked kryptonite but I would have to
introduce the band over this rolling
vamp you know and by when I got around
to Steve I'd often find myself stuck on
the stuff and it was a bit awkward and
uncomfortable and totally kills the vibe
you know so after a few instances of
this Steve happily became Steve and
we've got through it that way I've had a
lot of therapy and a common form of
treatment is to use this technique
that's called smooth speech which is
where you almost sing everything that
you say you kind of join everything
together in this very singsong
kindergarten teacher way and it makes
you sound very serene like you've had
lots of Valium and everything is fun
that's not actually me you know and I do
IIIi do use that I do I use it when I
have to be on panel shows oh when I have
to do radio interviews when the economy
of airtime is paramount
I get through it that way you know for
my for my job but as an artist who feels
that their work is is based solely on a
platform of honesty and being real that
feels often like cheating which is why
before I sing I wanted to tell you what
singing means to me it's more than
making nice sounds and it's more than
making nice songs it's more than feeling
known or understood it's more than
making you feel the things that I feel
it's not about mythology or
mythologizing myself to you somehow
through some miraculous synaptic
function of the human brain it's
impossible to stutter when you sing and
when I was younger that was a method of
treatment that worked very well for me
singing so I did it a lot and that's why
I'm here
today
[Applause]
[Music]
singing for me is sweet relief it is the
only time when I feel fluent it is the
only time when what comes out of my
mouth is comprehensively exactly what I
intended so I know that this is a TED
talk but now I'm going to Ted sing
this is a song that I wrote last year
thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
I would be a beauty Romano's slightly
too big for my face I would be a dreamer
my dream a slider to be for this space
I'll be an angel my hello it pairs in
the glow of your grace I would be a
joker ma look silly when you play
yours
I like to know other stars inhale I'd
like to know know
you can do they are making me lose
everything
oh no I cannot chew - oh no let go
[Music]
and I'd stay forever
my home is slightly too far from this
place
and I swear I tried to slow it down when
I
okay hey your pain
I think I threw the city's do I look
pretty
in the rain lovely makes me feel ugly so
much shame
I like to know I like to know know if
you can tell
[Music]
no I cannot choose to let go
[Music]
[Applause]